now
governments are coming under pressure as
demands for more accountability
and justice grow the reputation of many
leading political
and business figures has been tarnished
and the general public is losing
patience
i'm now joined in the studio by teresa
ireland
she's with the business ethics unit of
the cologne institute for economic
research welcome
to the studio teresa should we
get rid of tax havens altogether
well this is usually a suggestion that
is made in the aftermath of the panama
papers
but i would say that a general
suggestion in this case is not very
helpful but that we must approach the
topic more differentiated
in which way because there are usually
also some legal and also some
legitimate uses of share companies um
there are all sorts of combinations you
may use shell companies for
immoral and also illegal reasons these
are not to be discussed these topics
it's clear i think
but there are also some cases where
these
kinds of business models can actually be
helpful what would be a legitimate use
for a shell company and a tax saving
well if we talk about legitimate and
legal we must differentiate between the
the aspect of the law and the aspect of
what society expect
and a legitimate reason so what society
expect would certainly be
if a company wishes to acquire another
company
and does not want the price to rise so
in this case they can stay anonymous and
use a shar company to
bring the transaction to an end there
was a big fuss about the panama papers
recently but most of it wasn't illegal
most of what came out of it wasn't
illegal
yeah we still don't know the the whole
impact of the panama papers
but they certainly left another
impression then it did for example
the purchase of a cd with data from tax
evaders
it leaves a whole different impression
in the public and also on the politics
and this is usually due to the
identifiability of the offenders who are
named in the panama papers
how do we catch tax evaders what's the
most efficient way do we have to rely on
whistleblowers
whistleblowers are certainly one way and
they have
gained increasing importance during the
course of the last decades
but it's always a mixture of social
norms and also of legal
norms as we've seen in the case of
greece for example so
it would be helpful if a potential tax
evader didn't just hear from angela
merkel tax evasion that's not on at all
but also from his friend at the soccer
club but or maybe from his family member
very briefly if you can is the fight
against tax evasion winnable
i hope it is but i think it's at least
worth trying
very good there is iron there of the
business ethics unit of the cologne
institute for economic research thank
you very much
for coming to the studio